Salut !
Tu fais quoi là, Lolo ?
Je fais une caméra cachée.
Une quoi ?
Une caméra cachée.
Une caméra cachée...
Beh je sais pas...
Bonjour.
Salut.
Bon... On va commencer.
Donc...
Euh... Tu voulais dire un truc, je crois.
Oui.
Euh... Du coup je voulais juste profiter du fait qu'on soit tous ensemble,
pour vous dire que...
Beh voilà, je suis enceinte...
D'accord... Attends...
C'est nous que tu pièges en fait ?
Non... C'est pas...
T'es complétement con. Tu viens de nous dire "je fais une caméra cachée".
Tu nous l'as dit là en rentrant...
Tu nous dis : "je fais une caméra cachée", donc on le sait.
Beh tu sais pas où elle est cachée ?
Non, ce qu'il veut dire c'est que c'est pas le principe d'une caméra cachée.
Enfin tu sais pas où sont les caméras ; personne ne le sait !
Putain.
On s'en fout où elles sont, tu nous as dit que tu nous piégeais.
Donc c'est pas une caméra cachée, ça marche pas !
Du moment où vous ne savez pas où elles sont cachées, c'est une caméra cachée.
Donc une caméra cachée qui fonctionne avec des gens piégés.
Ah mais putain mais Lolo écoute-moi ! Sois pas sotte.
Je ne suis pas sotte.
Tes caméras tu les as cachées on ne sait pas où elles sont....
Ok d'accord ! Mais le principe d'une caméra cachée c'est pas seulement de cacher la caméra...
Qu'il faut cacher du coup...
Ce que veut dire Valentin avec ses mots à lui, qui ne sont pas forcément très clairs,
c'est que... on s'en fout ! D'accord ?
Ouais c'est ça.
C'est ça complètement.
Allez ! Réunion ! Ecrire des blagues...
Ouais enfin...
Non !
Oui, non mais si ! Je veux juste dire que quand même, vous ne savez pas où elles sont cachées.
Donc en soi, j'ai gagné, vous êtes des...
Mais ta gueule ! Ta gueule putain !
Je vais les trouver tes putains de caméras.
Là, il y en a pas ! Sur ta putain de gueule ! Hop une caméra !
Là ! Là il y a une putain de caméra, juste là !
Juste ici, il y a une caméra !
Là ! Là il y a carrément une ingé son en train de prendre le son !
Nickel !
Là putain !
Est-ce qu'on peut commencer cette putain de réunion s'il-vous-plaît !
C'est pas là...
Ok... Donc on se calme...
Il y a une caméra, là aussi.
Calme-toi Adrien !
Prends une chaise.
Voilà !
Je peux avoir des... Merci.
Il en reste une en fait...
Non ! Là !
Putain !
Ça va !
On prendra Justine Le Pottier.
Arrête !
Donc moi mon texte c'est une parodie de Game of Thrones, sauf que les personnages...
Enfin à la place de Tyrion ça pourrait...
Elle rigole...
Ouais je sais, je sais...